je suis élu par une majorité de
président de président de club qui m'a
encouragé à prendre sa décision surtout
des clubs qui font de la formation des
clubs qui est ce que je devrais vous
expliquer tout le travail qui est fait
pour former des jeunes
et puis est ce que je vais vous
expliquer quelle facilité qu'il y a de
prendre l'avion et d'aller à côté
chercher deux étrangers les payez pas en
moi vous faire du vélo face à notre
notre jeunesse qui travaillent qui va à
l'école
et puis je vous signale que en
martinique n'auraient pas encore un
comité qui gère des cyclistes
professionnels
c'est anti réglementaire
donc pour revenir sur cette relation
avec la ville de riga vilotte
c'est bien malheureux que le collègue
gastien qui au début n'était pas
d'accord du tout puisque pour avoir
discuté avec lui très tôt j'ai pris son
consentement à sont à son avis et puis
brusquement les choses ont changé ça
prouve en quelque part si le collet
gastien ça prouve en quelques pas que la
ville d'orillia pilotes à changer de
politique sportive et mène une politique
sportive avec des étrangers mois dans
les autres villes dans les autres
communes par exemple joseph le coince
fois le lamentin ça me plaît le voc est
de mener une politique sportif avec des
jeunes martiniquais pour les hommes les
mettre à vélo et qui est que deux mers
le répète suffisamment qu'on nous
puissions avoir des jeunes champions
martiniquais
moi je suis pas élu pour gérer le
cyclisme avec des étrangers moi je prend
la défense des jeunes martiniquais mais
c'est bien malheureux c'est bien
malheureux un espace de 1 en à peine dix
n'avaient avait sept huit seniors l'an
dernier de quoi ça vous donne raison
mais ça prouve quelque part que ces
jeunes menti qui était dans cette
équipe et qui ont constaté comment deux
étrangers est en mission au plateau ben
ils ont foutu le camp
vulgairement ils ont foutu le camp parce
qu'ils estiment que peut-être que le
club en fait beaucoup plus vous des
étrangers qu'on pouvait aujourd'hui ce
club de la pilotine n'a plus de
martiniquais
autour
d'un étranger donc ils se retrouvent il
inscrit que quatre coureurs
effectivement si on enlève un étranger
ils vont se retrouver à trois mais je
trouve que c'est malheureux c'est
malheureux des vocations possible oui pu
avoir des occasions possibles avec
l'accord premièrement de la fédération
la corde
de mon bureau mais pas pour deux
étrangers